before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
so
the last couple of these I I've really
tried to be more positive
that's gonna be real hard this time
survivors of the flux
here was the weird thing going into this
one
while
upon watching it I remembered nearly
everything that happened in it before
starting up the episode and trying to
think wait what was it that happened in
this episode
I couldn't remember a damn thing
and that's less a case of none of it's
taking my brain because as I said as I
saw all of it I'm like oh yeah I
remember this I remember this I remember
this but like it's so indistinct
that trying to figure out that any of
this happened specifically in this
episode it's
just fell out of my brain
this episode is basically nothing
but Exposition dump after Exposition
dump after Exposition dump
uh and some of the exposition dumps are
in the very literal sense like with tech
taiyoon expositing all about division
and everything else to the doctor some
of it is slightly better played
Exposition dumps as what it really is
ultimately what the all the stuff of the
grand serpent is it's just explaining
why he's here
sort of I still don't get
why he's like logistically I mostly get
how he's here I don't get why he's okay
I'm getting ahead of myself
this one's a mess
and it is a mess
I was gonna say on the order of
Halloween apocalypse it might actually
be worse
we'll see what I think when I see the
next episode but this this might be the
worst episode of this series the worst
episode of flux cause
you know as much of a mess as Halloween
apocalypse is and it is a mess
I at least get that for everything
that's going to be going on which is way
too much there are tons of plots that
just should have been excised but for
everything that is going on like I at
least get why that's a mess and then you
have War of the centaurans which has
some fun and then you have Once Upon
Time which had way more positive
qualities than I remembered it being
without actually crossing over into good
and uh Village of the Angels once I knew
that I didn't like the ending already I
was able to zoom in and focus on how
much did work with the atmosphere and
the I guess performances most of them so
like I'm still finding stuff to be like
oh okay and then we get to this and it's
like oh
I said I was trying
I'm trying to find the good in this and
it's not completely devoid of good it's
not 100 absence
just you know the good is about
90 absent
out of gas
because honestly like I kind of enjoy
the companions
the rollicking globetrotting Indiana
Jones Style Adventure that Dan Yaz and
Professor Jericho are on
I kind of wish that was the whole
episode
because I'm just enjoying their Dynamic
I'm liking the way that they bounce off
each other and it's just a general feel
and kind of a niche genre that I just
like
I like rolling globetrotting treasure
hunting Adventure stuff I like Indiana
Jones I like the Brendan Fraser mummy
like I like that stuff I just do so
that's fun and entertaining and as has
happened honestly across all of her
appearances another few moments of
actually doing quite a good job at
characterizing Yaz which
continues to make me frustrated that she
wasn't given the central place of
prominence way way way before power of
the doctor and she should have been the
only companion I'd say since series 12
but definitely for this as much as Dan I
actually kind of like he's a nice person
but like
there's these moments where we get good
characterization on Yaz and then I'm
like and uh they could have really
drilled into that here there's just so
they're on this ship and somebody comes
and tries to kill them
it's implied that they work for the
grand serpent
how he knows they're there even in this
timeline or what they're doing or that
they should die I don't remember ever
getting established but regardless
somebody's trying to kill them and they
take this guy out and they're like well
what do we do with this and yes just
very coldly then come Nightfall when
it's quiet shove his body overboard
walked and again that that sort of
very tactically minded that sort of
knuckling down and going okay
I enjoy what we do but right now this is
not fun this is businesses work this is
get the job done and there's that in
like just the moments of her tapping
into what was very clearly a lot of her
police training just really gives he has
a nice texture and layer as a character
that we largely just get in glimpses
because she doesn't ever really get a
proper highlight across all of our time
see even the stuff that I kind of like I
have a hard time talking about without
it reminding me of other stuff that I
don't like and look as much of a cliche
uh sort of a it's weird to say cliche
because it's subversive but it's been
done so often that it's a very
unsubversive subversion of like the
like the ancient wise person on some
remote place like actually being you
know very affable and wanting to know
the latest gossip and you know if it had
not been set at the turn of the 20th
century he would have been going hey do
you need to jump on the Wi-Fi like
that's what the joke would have been as
much as that has kind of become uh like
a bottom of the barrel really easy
low-hanging fruit of subversion
I still have fun with it and the guy who
was playing this kind of seeer like he
was clearly having fun with it I don't
get to tease people much
so while I can't claim that it's good
and it's certainly not original material
it's still fun I enjoy that and again
tying into
um the companions jumping around back in
1904. uh they don't really say who the
hell they left Peggy with
from the previous episode the little kid
who's going to be stuck growing into the
old woman in that damn Village
They Don't Really cover
where she is not that I expected her to
tag along I don't but like just a line
just a line accounting for where she
ended up
um
so that's honestly kind of the strongest
material I can give you oh the um the
tunnel guy the liver Liverpool tunnel
guy who's name is escaping me uh he
finally has a purpose because we realize
that there's all these different doors
within the tunnels and they go different
places different times different worlds
and but now in the wake of the flux they
have changed and like this is largely a
plot contrivance this largely exists to
be able to solve some things later and
to allow some things to
um connect to each other that otherwise
they don't have a means to get to each
other because as calvinist himself
points out even when he spots the
message that is intended for him I don't
have time trouble you idiot I can't
actually do anything with that
information I still like calvinist a
fair bit his his grouchiness is actually
quite endearing to me I enjoy him
but we have this guy down on the tunnels
and he's finally given a purpose but
he's also given a moment of actual
humanization
because up to this point he's just been
the weird guy obsessed with tunnels just
wandering around out of time
intermittently he just keeps showing up
and then Vanishing and he's just Gruff
and annoyed with everybody but then when
Yaz says what it is that she understands
is going on
the relief
on his face
that's actually a real great moment
kind of a powerful moment like they
actually gave the actor something to act
as opposed to you know just generic ah b
b grouchy hmm no he genuinely tapped
into something very human there and
again in a way that I feel like you
could have given at least half an
episode over to really digging into this
guy there's stuff going on with him that
is interesting and that the actor can
clearly bring forward
but there isn't time so it doesn't
happen
the grand serpent so why is he here
and I mean that both kind of somewhat
logistically but also massively as a
meta-narrative thing why is he here
because I'm still
there's a lot of
in the wake of all of the freaking
exposition
uh the worst Expo dumps being from the
Dr hologram to Yaz uh which does also
have some good moments I'll come back to
that in a second but also between tecton
and the doctor with all of this
Exposition it is delivered so flatly
that I have a really hard time absorbing
it and virtually none of it is backed up
by actual visualization and plot points
it's just stuff that's said so I think I
think between what the two of them said
they kind of cover for why a bunch of
people are displaced from time and space
and where they're supposed to be and I
think that's meant to cover
for the grand Serpent and why he's he is
in the time period we see him
it doesn't
really work though because everything
about the way he's presented and his
Framing and his performance isn't I
don't know how I ended up here and I'm
making the best of it it's I'm here with
purpose and a plan
why
how
like if they're trying to have it be
like he's just trying to make the the
best of a bad situation that's not
brought across because again everything
about the performances is
um brought in at that level that's like
yes everything's going according to my
plan I've been I've been plotting this
for a long time and I actually feel kind
of bad bagging on the grand serpent
story because I mentioned this when he
got introduced an episode or two ago
dude's got good presence he's got good
villainous presence I actually think he
could have been a really good villain if
he was allowed to be the main villain of
not even necessarily this story just of
something
I think he could have been real good and
I actually even kind of like that we've
got this sort of bumbling Upper Crust
Posh sort of failing upwards type that
he attaches himself to he's like oh yes
it's Jolly exciting isn't it oh all this
alien stuff you know the kind of person
who gets a position of power simply
because of who they're related to
probably and has no business in that job
and just as soon as he meets somebody he
thinks is close to his class level and
knows what they're doing he's very happy
to just shunt off responsibility as much
as possible as quickly as possible do
you think so
yes I must have been on a little at Sea
it's not my area of expertise honest
honestly early days of unit when it
wouldn't have been taken that seriously
yeah I buy that I buy that that works
and as I said the grand serpent himself
is performance is solid he's got a good
intimidation Factor
I do like him but I don't
I don't get why he's here there's the
logistical thing like I mentioned I
don't get why he's here
but there's also just the meta narrative
I don't understand why there are
Four villains
five kind of four and a half
four and a half villains to this
six-part thing
four and a half villains and a
cataclysmic event so swarmin Azure
that's one and yes I'm counting two as
one because like functionally they're
one character so the swarm of azure
there's tecton and division there's the
grand serpent there's the sontarens
there's your four I'll give you another
half for the Weeping Angels they are
working for division but they get enough
of a highlight I'll count them as their
own kind of half thing and actually add
add up to a total of five by putting the
cataclysmic event of the flex itself as
the other half so there's effectively by
the weird math I've decided I'm gonna do
like five villains in this thing
why
what well
we know why because this was supposed to
have more episodes than it did and it
got cut down and they scrambled to try
and rework it and they didn't have the
time to massage this properly I think
given more time
and especially considering a lot of
these parts probably had been cast
already given more time they might have
sat down and realized okay there's
actually huge stuff we just need to
excise from this like we need to ditch
either the grand serpent or swarmint
Azure because there's no wow it's
debatable whether there's point to
either of them being there but there's
definitely no reason for them to both be
there especially when division is
actually following up on stuff we've
done and is laid out at the at this
point in this episode as the actual
cause of the flux so division tectayune
cool it's following up on stuff from the
end of the previous series stuff I don't
like but it should still be followed up
on there's a reason she's there there's
a reason division is there they cause
the flux cool consider that mandatory
the santarans taking advantage
doesn't dominate this so much of the
narrative and is kind of fun I'm like
you maybe could have gotten away with
that one but swarming Azure and the
grand serpent why I mean why are they
here
why especially I'm just jumping around
at this point Follow Me If You Can
especially considering that towards the
end swarmint is your just
wandering to the exposition room and
kill Tech tayune and take over the story
for the last episode what was the point
of bringing back and trying to in any
way characterize Tech taeyoon which
isn't done very well not because the
actress isn't good she's selling it the
best that she can but because
she's only there to give Exposition and
there's very little time to actually
characterize her as anything other than
vaguely villainous you can practically
hear somebody from just off screen going
okay that's all the explanation we need
from her kill her now please get her off
the screen and like
I don't like the idea of well the
Timeless child at all I don't like the
idea of tech taehyun I don't think she
works but she is by far the most valid
villain for this piece
she's the one who has the history with
the doctor I mean history that we don't
actually know so that supposed history
that we're told to exists is actually
functionally meaningless and doesn't
exist but in theory
she has the most direct history to the
doctor she directly ties into the thing
you ended the previous series with she's
tied to division which the doctor had
kicked off this thing looking for she's
responsible for the flux and if you're
going to ever try and sell this idea of
the doctor's mother betrayed her then
you need to take the time to make this a
proper character and sell us on that
because they still are trying the way
it's presented and she goes I am Tech
tell you and it's treated like a big
deal like
lady we heard your name for the first
time like five or six episodes ago that
was the first time we'd heard it ever
and since then we've gotten no fill in
on you you are a name you are a concept
we know nothing about you we're not
invested in you
you can say this all day long but the
show has not made us care about who Tech
taeyoon is so they just shows us where
he goes I'm titanium like okay so you're
that thing that I remember being brought
up that annoys me but she has a lot more
validity to be the villain and you could
have done more you know her scenes in
here are an exposition dump but with
that out of the way you could have
actually done something proper with her
as a character exploration is just
getting some actual relationship between
her and the doctor a proper one in the
next episode but nope nope nope she's
dead now so that swarming Azure can be
our closing villains and while I've
slightly defended softball kind of
defended swarming Azure uh in previous
episodes saying you know the Design's
kind of cool and the performances are
solid given how unnecessary and Arch
they are and I stand by that but that
doesn't make them the correct villains
for this story
and they're still talking these weird
vague terms they've got all these people
around these batteries and they're like
you are space how we are time
hmm
it's all these vagaries and like I can
work with vague unexplained stuff
especially in Doctor Who sometimes I
wish there was more of it but like I
don't get what's going on or why or why
they care or why they're free or why we
had the flashback with them before why
their previous stuff on the planet
called time but they themselves are also
worshiping time but they say they are
time like it it's starting to sound like
Kingdom Hearts the heartless they take
your heart and then they move without
our heart and your heart is given to
Darkness Darkness Darkness nobody
Darkness heartless heart
that's what it's starting to sound like
it's exhausting and exasperating
and there's just like
I kind of let go the plot contrivance of
the tunnels because like at least we get
a decent character beat for the one guy
that's the only one it gets really
but there's also the absolute complete
contrivance of the stragglers are
centering on earth and the flux will
will end at Earth
why
Earth matters to the doctor why does
Earth matter to everybody freaking else
this is actually part of the problem I
have with how much of modern day who
either takes place on or is in other in
some other way centered around Earth and
humans I know oftentimes it's a
logistical even budgetary thing because
it's just easier to make this stuff work
if you don't have to build you know
intricate space station or otherworldly
sets all the damn time I do get that
logistically but like
I just think back to say series four
with the uh with the stolen planets and
Earth ends up being one of them like
thankfully at least there's enough of
them that is like okay that's just bad
luck Earth happens to be one of them but
and of course it's the last one that has
yo it's always oh it just happens to be
Earth just happens to be Earth they you
know
this alien species could have executed
this plan that they're doing on any
Planet but it happens to be Earth the
the flux could have ended anywhere it
happens to be Earth it's it's just
seeing the hand of the author and trying
to force it to be more dramatic and we
also get laid out the fact that a lot of
the universe is missing and destroyed
and I'm gonna try and focus really hard
on seeing if that get because like to my
memory
that doesn't get fixed but it also
doesn't get addressed
so I got to keep an eye on that for next
time that's assuming I can't even follow
it
because like
I need a flow chart
I need a week and about I I need a week
and five conspiracy boards to make sense
of this thing it's just all these
stories stepping on each other and a lot
of which could have been decent in and
of themselves there were glimmers and
glimpses of decent stuff in here and
even decent complete character and story
arcs vendor comes back just to be caught
and tossed into passenger for
no reason and die is still in there for
no established reason like we know that
the ravagers kind of tormented damn with
the fact that they had her but they're
not actually leveraging that for
anything and how did they know that she
was tied to him and why do they care and
why like hey
trying to make sense of this thing hurts
my head
cause it's just
it's it's trying
so hard
to establish everything that needs to be
established
you know from the previous four episodes
in order to get us to the finale
but since there's so many things that
shouldn't be here at all that either
should have been streamlined excised
um or otherwise can uh simplified and
condensed but it's all still here then
we just have an episode trying
desperately
to make it all make sense but you can't
you can't not in the time you have
if flux was as an overall thing was ever
going to work
it needs
minimum minimum two more full episodes
than it has
and that's bare minimum
I would say it needs
three
but it didn't have them
and while
I would say possibly with the exception
of Halloween apocalypse because that one
was it was largely a setup episode but
at the very least the three between that
one and this
we're still trying to give a story
a narrative I mean the thinnest one was
once upon time but it was still trying
to tell some story elements and actually
give us you know something something
some kind of Revolution within to some
degree what was going on within that
episode and and then were the santarans
and Village of the angels are close ish
to stand alone or at least
sizable aspects of Lamar
this isn't trying to do anything other
than info dump info dump info dump I
said I was going to come back to Yaz and
the doctor hologram again when it's not
just the doctor dropping Exposition some
nice little character moments for the
doctor for Yaz and by this point they
knew they were working their way towards
actually shipping these two and as far
as groundwork for that goes it's solid
enough I suppose
but it's a nice moment
aside from the clunky Exposition that
Jody's stuck with I I feel really bad
for Jody Whitaker
because when she's allowed to actually
Act
when she's allowed to actually be a
character and not just the person asking
what's going on or telling everyone else
what's going on which is allowed to
actually
be a character and not an exposition
machine
she's really good
but she is called upon to just deliver
the exposition and explain the story
that you're watching
so often
including in this she's either
explaining it or she's prompting Tech
taehyun to explain it
she is used as a vehicle for exposition
way more than she's actually allowed to
be a character and it's a real real
shame
because when she is allowed to be a
character she's good
she's a lot better than the material she
was given
and it's it's a shame that's just where
I'm at with this one
I suppose in some ways I did find some
good to talk about it just I couldn't
talk about it as its own thing like
here's the good here's the bad the good
is all stymied and not allowed to be as
good as it could have been because of
all the bad that it ties into
this one this one hurt this one hurt to
watch
um I would say uh of the five that I've
seen I've got one more to go to finish
the flux re-watch
of the five that I've seen this one this
one was the one that hurt to revisit
and I say that as someone who like
hasn't really super enjoyed most of the
rewatch but you know finding some stuff
that I'm like oh okay there is some good
there and even like being disappointed
re-watching War of the santarans and
realizing the stuff I liked was not
nearly as high a percentage of the
episode as my memory said that it was
even with that disappointment in there
like there was still stuff I could find
and even Halloween Apocalypse at the
very loose at very very least was
introducing stuff that I could still be
like yeah like I mentioned Dan's
introduction way better than I
remembered it being calvinist is fun
there's some good stuff in there
there's so little of the good stuff in
here and there isn't a single beat of
good stuff in this episode that it isn't
in some way having its potential stamped
on
by the lumbering Behemoth that is this
overarching plot this overstuffed
undercooked mess is suffocating what
good there is in this
and it's really frustrating
and I'm sorry I'm sorry that it got this
negative again I was actually feeling
really good about the fact that I
managed to make the last two of these
more positive than I was expecting to I
felt really good about that and I wanted
to do that here I can't though
I can't I can't even really get mad
about it because it's not bad in the
kind of way that infuriates me like hell
bent or the Timeless children does
or even you know the kind of deeply
offensive that I find something like the
idiots Lantern it's not any of those
it's just a mess
it is the epitome
of I'm not mad
I'm just really disappointed
survivors of the flux
you rewatched this one lately what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills enables me to do
this as my living uh even if you can't
help me out there there's links down in
the description for other things that I
do I have merch I'm on other platforms
etc
etc don't worry too much about it though
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meeting and until next time this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
foreign
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]